[Music]
the first race that i competed against a
transgender athlete was
during my freshman year
[Music]
and once the gun went off the two
transgender athletes took off flying and
left all of us girls in the dust
throughout all four years of high school
i was forced to compete against
biological males i only competed against
them in the sprinting events but i raced
against these athletes over a dozen
times throughout the years and every
single time i lost did they inch you out
of
medals that you would have won otherwise
or trophies you would they beat me out
by 20 meters out of medals and
qualifying spots i missed out on
qualifying for new england i had i had
to go in the long jump and the 4x200
meter relay so i was forced on the
sidelines in my own event and if they
were not there i would have been able to
qualify so i missed out on so much
throughout my high school career did
they win
all the events or almost all the events
between the two of them they won every
single event they competed in how does
that how does that feel
it is so
frustrating and heartbreaking because we
elite female athletes train so hard to
shave distractions of a second off of
our time and going into races knowing
that we will never be able to win feels
like all that work gone to waste
it does after so many losses it just
gets to the point of why am i even doing
this why am i keep
training so hard and sacrificing so much
just to place third and beyond